this episode of the minimalist is
brought to you by mountain dew baja
blast
the best flavor of mountain dew use
promo code poison
just kidding this is brought to you by
nobody advertisements suck let's start
the show
this podcast has bad words
hello everybody welcome to the
minimalist podcast where we discuss what
it means to live a meaningful life with
less my name is joshua fields milburn
and i'm ryan nicodemus and together we
are the minimalists ryan we all want
things yeah but you ever thought about
why you want what you want
actually we should tell our audience if
they buy all our books
especially if they pre-order love people
use things if they watch our
documentaries
yes and they listen to all our podcasts
they'll never want anything again
right wouldn't it be great if that was
true
yeah we had the answers and so what
we're gonna do today is we're gonna sort
of interrogate where our desires
come from today we're joined by luke
burgess he's the author of one thing
i'll hold this up if you're watching
on youtube which is also where you can
comment on this episode
this is a brand new book it just came
out on june 1st
and you can check it out now we'll put a
link to it in the show notes
we're going to discuss how we can free
ourselves from chasing
unfulfilling desires luke thanks for
being here brother thanks for having me
on guys
pleasure to have you so ours is the
listener-driven show we're going to get
into some questions here shortly
but i thought maybe we could start out
by talking about why we want
what we want what are what's this
concept of memetic desire
yeah medic is kind of a fancy word right
it essentially means that we
want things because other people
want them all right and it's usually
because
we feel like we lack something that they
have
so our desires are not generated the way
that a lot of people think they are from
some secret
chamber of desire inside of me where
there's a one-to-one relationship
between me and the things that i want
desire according to renee girard who is
the inspiration behind my book
is something relational so desires are
shaped in the relationship between
people people who model desires to us
in different ways so if we're stranded
on a desert
a deserted island right all of a sudden
our desires are going to change
considerably from what they are right
now we may have some sort of innate
desires
you know food and and sleep and sex i
get tired i want to sleep right
i get hungry i want to eat i get horny i
want to have sex
and and yet beyond that even and even
those things are shaped you know
the joke of the baja blast thing like no
one has an innate desire for
a poisonous drink right it just happens
to be that that
is promulgated by media and by culture
and by advertising to make us want
certain things that we don't necessarily
inherently want
exactly so you make a really good
distinction if you were stranded on a
desert island
if you were born on a desert island
there are certain things you simply
couldn't want
because you hadn't even been exposed to
models for
certain kinds of desires for mountain
dew and just [ __ ] things that we
don't need right right
so you're limited in what you can want
so our wants are kind of circumscribed
by the models that we have in our lives
so you're right there's biological wants
but i think they're better described as
needs so you know human being if we're
thirsty we want to drink if we're hungry
we want to eat if we're horny we want to
have sex and all those things right
but once we get outside of the realm of
instinctual response
how do we know how to choose one object
versus another so like the more abstract
things get
the more reliant we become on models
like
careers like lifestyles the more
abstract the more we rely
on some kind of external uh signpost
because we don't have a biological one
right and this isn't inherently a bad
thing either it's just understanding
it helps us better understand what
drives us to do what we do right
yeah and you know very often we just
take our desires for granted like
i want this thing because it's good for
me and we don't actually take the time
to
question why we're pursuing this thing
in the first place
and even good for me is sort of a
cultural construct to a great extent
if you were on that deserted island and
you were born there
you wouldn't really know good for me bad
for me in the sort of philosophical
sense you would know like pain and
pleasure
and maybe that's how we identify good
and bad unfortunately i think right now
our desires often lead to our misery the
objects of our desire
are making us miserable you know i i'm
familiar with your stories and i think
we all
actually have a lot in common because
early in my life my
desires the things that i thought were
going to make me really happy made me
totally miserable even though i had a
lot of
things that i thought that i wanted i
would get them i'd be happy for a day
and some things happened in my life that
made me stop and pause and say like what
in the hell am i
relentlessly pursuing these things for
kind of forced me to stop and take stock
in my life and prioritize my values
and try to get to the origin of my
desires and go
back into my past and try to figure out
where some of these things came from in
the first place
because they were making me miserable
right yeah
so i'm guessing mimetic desire i mean
it's
mimicking is is is that a derivative of
myth
okay it is right cool yeah yeah so we
mimic other people
including our desires they're memetic it
basically when we talk about the concept
of memetic desire it just means
the question i often ask people is do
you want what you want or did someone
else tell you to want it
almost always it's someone else not a
literal person but a culture society
religion
etc that has influenced our desire right
yeah and this aspect of human nature and
i do believe it is part of what it means
to be human
is not a bad thing like you said it's
we're social creatures right we care
what other people want
we're influenced by the people and
models in our lives
and that's what allows us to enter into
like beautiful relationships and there
can be positive models of desire
if we have negative ones we can take an
inventory of the relationships
and we can swap them out for positive
influences so
the idea that we're memetic is a little
unpalatable to some people
because we live in this hyper individual
individualistic age right
where it's like no i'm not memetic
actually one of the somebody read my
book and was like
yeah this isn't for me like that this
applies to everybody else like i'm not
influenced by this stuff right i'm not
but it's like no i mean we're actually
at a deep level like you have to
understand this is not a bad
thing right like i want to be influenced
by positive
models of desire in my life right yeah
and so if you think it's not for you
it's probably most for you because
that's the the final illusion is like oh
yeah it does look like everyone else is
influenced by everyone else
yeah except me i'm different i'm unique
and
what you're saying and i know you even
talk about this in your book is
that that sort of the dissolving of that
illusion
it takes a while for us because maybe
it's hubris maybe it's
the ego whatever it is it leads us to
say well
well no i'm different my desires are my
own
everyone else's desires are are well
they might be influenced by someone else
but yeah i'm better than that i'm
stronger than that i'm a
good person or whatever it might be i'm
not a follower right
right i got all these lemmings and pawns
all around me yes
you know it's funny conversely like i
think about people i don't know i went
to high school with maybe some adults
like this probably too
but they look at what the cool kids like
and then they automatically
like eschew that oh the cool kids like
this band i don't like that band i like
this
yeah so not not only are you uh you know
mimicking but then you're like choosing
a group of people that you don't want to
be like so you're choosing the opposite
of what they choose in a way that is
kind of
a memetic desire it is i mean it's like
kind of like nobody thinks they're a
hipster right that's what they're doing
rejecting the popular culture and then
they all kind of end up looking alike
right right so that's something i would
call negative imitation right you're
still
taking the culture as a model
and you're rejecting it not necessarily
realizing that it still has a tremendous
influence over you
you're just imitating it or reacting to
it in a negative way
well we've got some audience questions
here let's start with facebook we have a
question from
willem how do you find fulfilling
desires
after years of minimizing in several
areas of my life i find i have very few
desires left
even though i feel peaceful and content
i miss the energy that comes
with enthusiasm for something
this energy makes me think that another
word could be pleasure
almost i feel like we could insert that
there yeah i
agree so luke if we're looking at this
you know it's fascinating because
fulfilling desires so we we often think
of
okay now that i'm analyzing this some of
my desires have been
unfulfilling yeah and we often realize
that through trial and error as you did
as ryan and i did as i did
it's oh you know what all the things i
thought i wanted isn't actually what i
necessarily wanted
or maybe another way to put that this is
something pithy for you podcast john
is um the thing you want is never the
thing you want
and and so when i think about our
our influences there as we start to
unpack these what we're really searching
for
is more fulfilling desires and at the
same time
what william is saying is yeah but i
still want that burst of
pleasure as well yeah we're not
anti-pleasure
but but also understanding that
satisfaction or pleasure is different
from fulfillment
yeah i mean i want i don't want to
desire less
i only want to desire less of the things
that will ultimately bring me misery and
i want to desire
more of the things that will bring me
fulfillment so it's a matter of ordering
our desires
right some desire i mean desire is not a
bad thing desire is beautiful it's what
it means to be human
how we love right so it's a matter of
ordering our desires and discerning
which ones lead to where so what i would
suggest to your listener
maybe a good place to start is to kind
of take inventory of your past
go back in your life and ask yourself
you know what were those things that i
did what were those actions that i
undertook
that did bring me a deep sense of joy
and satisfaction
right dig them up and try to string
together three or four of those stories
and see if you can identify
some pattern to what it was that brought
you fulfillment
because that's probably a little key a
little signpost
to something that really matters to you
and is truly meaningful
and it's probably going to guide you to
the kinds of desires that you want to
cultivate in the future
why do we why do we stray off that path
though because we find something that's
fulfilling
and then we always want more and more
and more in our culture we never stop to
consider
less of just about anything right it's
it's constantly consuming
and constantly wanting and assuming that
more desire
equals good or inherently noble or
something
and that's not what we're saying we're
also not saying get rid of your your
desires
but it sounds like we find something
fulfilling and then for whatever reason
we we tend to stray from that
is that because we're of the external
influences still
yeah you know we tend it's like almost a
flaw
in in human nature you know uh
we always think that we lack something
in order to be happy and we go through
life the reason that we adopt different
models is because we think that
they have something that we don't have
you know this
especially if somebody's really
confident in what they want and
confident in their desires
they become a very powerful model to us
another word
for that might be idle right and
as soon as we get what they had
and we're not happy we just assume well
maybe they were just the wrong model but
guess what there's
you know what seven and a half other
billion models in the world so
now i just go in search of a new one
yeah and that's a game that just
never ends yes indeed wow well i'm
listening to your copy of wanting it's
luke's
new book enjoy that book we have a
question here from
is it shay in arkansas yeah i decided to
design a way to pay off my debt as soon
as possible
based on your advice that no debt is
good debt
after running this plan by some trusted
family members
i received some advice that paying off
my house as aggressively as i had
originally planned
might be bad because it might not leave
me with enough cash on hand should i
face
some sort of financial crisis either
personally or nationally
i was interested in what your advice is
on a proper balance of
paying off your mortgage quickly while
making sure you have enough cash on hand
should you face any kind of extenuating
circumstance
so shay you're right we often say that
there's no such thing as good debt in
fact we're just on dave ramsey show
um a few weeks ago and and but people
often mistake that when we say there's
no such thing as good debt
what does our mind straight to all debt
is bad debt well what i mean is there's
no such thing as morally good debt i'm
not saying that it's morally bad to have
debt either
what i'm simply saying is it removes
pieces of your freedom and so if you
desire to have freedom as i do
but then i also might desire to have a
giant house
well i they're mutually exclusive if i'm
going to have
a massive amount of debt here it is
going to tether me to something which by
definition
removes pieces of my freedom right and
so
well i never want to have debt i don't
want to have a
a big house with a big mortgage i don't
have a car payment i certainly don't
have credit card debt or payday lender
debt
the the debtor is slave to the lender i
i believe that
but it doesn't mean that i'm telling you
or prescribing to you that you
should do something and there is a
morally right way to approach these
things
because i think in a weird way luke that
would be a type of you know
memetic prescription in a way where like
and by the way i think we're smitten
with these sort of the how to's and the
prescriptions from all over the place
and then we get all of this sort of
conflicting advice and we just end up
confused and so i think maybe there's a
question sort of behind
this question what do you actually want
if you want
freedom then of course i'm going to work
to pay that house off as quickly as
possible
if you're comfortable with giving up
some pieces of your freedom
then maybe it's not that big of a deal
to you
you're also worried about having enough
cash on hand for emergencies well i mean
of course having an emergency fund
is something that i have uh three to six
months i try to have six months of
of income so that if something were to
happen the internet explodes you lose a
job whatever
all of a sudden you have the ability to
still provide for yourself for a period
of time as you
sort things out again that's not what
you should do
it's just something that has worked for
me and i know it's worked for ryan and
thousands of other people as well
yeah for sure i think like what i hear
shay kind of
uh showing us here is that when we have
these desires
we have to be very clear on what those
desires
are going to cost us so for shea it's
going to cost her
liquid funds to um
to cover an emergency if one should
happen so yeah i think that's i think
that's great but
you know maybe there is a broader
question here with
how do we filter through these desires
is it just a matter of weighing out the
opportunity cost is it a matter of like
looking at our values and looking at our
beliefs and
deciding deciding what what desires are
going to serve us
um but i guess like do you have any
advice on sifting through
all of these desires that that come into
our lives
memetic desire one way to think about it
would be borrowed desires like a highly
memetic
desire you're sort of borrowing desire
from somebody else
so in my life in 2008 when i had this
really
crisis turning point in my life my sky
high level of
debt was basically a proxy from my level
of memetic desire
so there's some relationship between
debt
and memetic desire and for me
this is a very personal decision right
personal finances so
i just went through a process of saying
what's really really important to me
why did i buy a house in 2008 when i
really probably shouldn't have because
i just moved to vegas and i wasn't quite
sure what the next year was going to
hold
i bought it because like owning a house
was
what i should be doing yes after because
i had a certain level of success i
needed to have a certain house
with a certain you know amount of square
feet and a backyard and all this
[ __ ] right
absolutely and you're supposed to do
you'd be irresponsible
if you didn't i mean we hear all these
sort of cultural memes
which are the they themselves the the
drivers of mimetic desire
yeah so i you know here i was left
holding the bag
on this big house when the real estate
market crashed and it was bad in vegas
right
it was one of the worst and i just had a
moment i was like i don't
i don't want to be in debt like ever
again
so i made some really important
decisions at that particular time in my
life
to you know to shed myself of all debt
all credit cards
um mortgages i'm not an investment
advisor here we probably need to do some
disclaimers
um but when interest rates are low from
what i understand it can make sense
right to carry the mortgage right
yeah it can make sense monetarily but
just because something makes sense
monetarily it doesn't take
into consideration the the sort of
non-monetary costs right the
the psychological costs the emotional
cost of owning the thing
you have to take i mean your psychology
matters a lot and
when i talk to a lot of people about
stocks and crypto and should i invest in
this should i invest in that
right and everybody wants to get into
the technical arguments and i'm just
like
if you buy that if you put x percentage
of your money in that will you be able
to sleep at night
and if the answer is no like what's the
cost of that on your relationship
yes yeah we don't talk about the
internal personal stuff
enough yeah well let's let's dig into
that a little bit more because
there are all of these additional costs
and we often think about debt and owning
possessions
we start with the price tag and that's
one cost for sure
and then we just sort of dismiss it i
can either afford it because i have the
cash in the bank or
if some lender is going to loan me the
money and i can quote afford the payment
by the way if it requires you to finance
something you by definition can't afford
it i mean that's just
in our society i know that's almost
sacrilegious to say i'm just saying
definitionally
it's like numerator denominator thing if
you don't have the money to pay for the
thing you can't afford it
uh i that's like grandma's wise advice
and now it's
it seems like uh it's anathema to to
even say
something like that right and so um but
let's let's talk about some of those
other
costs that you know society or the
memetic beliefs or the
memetic desires thrust upon us yeah
there's personal
and relationship costs there's different
layers of costs
and it's worth examining all the
different costs because the financial
one is just the beginning
so early in my life i was paying what i
call a misery tax
expand on that so i would work 12 hour
days in my startup
and at the end of the day i needed to
consume
things to feel better yes okay
drinking too much eating too much you
know going to the strip
and you know just pissing my money away
playing blackjack or whatever was right
that was basically a misery tax that i
was playing
in order pain in order to feel better
about myself
to go to bed and wake up the next day
and do the same thing all over again
and those things right there was a
personal
toll to that that added up like not
getting enough sleep right
impacting my health so the financial
cost
of me you know going out to some fancy
dinner and you know ordering you know
fancy cocktails for all of my friends
and everything like that
you know was not cheap but there was a
more personal cost that i had to pay
in regards to my health my well-being
you know relationships that i wasn't
cultivating yes
just to buy things to help me feel a
little bit better
about the things that i didn't really
want to be doing during the course of
the day
wow misery tax that is that's huge it
makes me think i
makes me think about this advice i got
one time from a friend he basically said
you know anything you do in life
you have to ask yourself like is it
serving
you and in the way uh in the person that
you want to become
or is it taking away from you and uh
that
there's something there with the uh with
the
oh what did you call it the uh the
misery tax yeah
and and that's it's kind of a i mean
that's another way to look at it i guess
like anything that we do you've got to
ask yourself
like is this actually serving who i want
to become right and if it isn't and
you're gonna do it anyway and you're
acting off of impulse that's when it
becomes a misery tax
misery tax is like the zero-sum game
it's like just trying to help you get to
the next day
and just deal with a life that you're
really not happy with yeah
so i think we have to kind of evaluate
the things that like the way that we
spend money through the lens of
who is this helping me become right and
the longer view we can take the better
10 15 years from now will i look back
at these decisions after they've
compounded for years
who will that have helped me become
mm-hmm and so in a way what we're
talking about here is
is this helping me become the person i
want to become or is this
forcing forcing me to become the person
someone else wants me to become
or a group of others a collective others
want me to become
because that's just going to continue to
make me miserable speaking of money shea
i'm going to send you a copy of our
new book it comes out next month it is
called love people
use things because the opposite never
works if you want the book book or the
e-book we'll send those to you or you
want the audio book ryan and i are going
to read it to you shay we're personally
going to come to your house and read the
entire book it's a live audio book
session
in fact it's a relationship book but
it's about the seven essential
relationships in our lives how we heal
those relationships
and one of those relationships is our
relationship with money
we have a tumultuous relationship with
money in our culture
and because of it it's making us
miserable i mean talk about a misery tax
our relationship with money is is one of
the things that breaks up relationships
it breaks up businesses partnerships
friendships
all because we do we we have this
awful misunderstood relationship
with money it's created a lot of pain in
our lives so one of the chapters in here
is about our relationship with money
shay i think you'll enjoy that
we'll put a link to this in the show
notes by the way it helps out if you
pre-order the book
if you pre-order it head on over to
lovepeopleusethings.net
and you can find all the different
versions over there ryan what time is it
you know what time it is it's time for
our lightning round where we answer your
text messages you can text your
questions and comments to 937-202-4654
yes indeed now
luke during the lightning round that's
where ryan and i do our best to answer
questions with a short shareable less
than 140 character response
but not really we just monitor on a bit
and then we we put something pithy in
the show notes so people can copy and
share our pithy answers on social media
by the way if you text that phone number
we'll also send you our minimal maxims
every
monday a monday morning minimal maximum
we'll never send you
spam or or junk or advertisements but
you can text us
anything in fact texas emoji of the
thing you got rid of most recently
937-202-4654 brenda has a question for
us
how do we recognize and address the
influences especially those online
that promote mindless consumption we're
made to feel as if we should
have certain things because other people
have them which makes us feel
incomplete so let's talk about the you
know these new influences we have you
know we've been heavily mediated to for
the past hundred or so years but
especially with
social media i know in the book you
actually you talk about how it's not
really media in a way
so let's expand on that a bit there's a
lot of talk about how
social media is addicting i think we
have to ask
how is it addicting now i know there's
good evidence that it is
neurologically physiologically addicting
i mean it gives us dopamine hits
the way that the notifications appear on
my phone
when somebody replies to a tweet or
something like that it's like a slot
machine right it's these intermittent
variable rewards
i don't really know what it says so i i
just can't stand not to click in it
so you know that's true i mean this
stuff definitely affects our our brains
we have the vegas strip in your pocket
now the biggest strip in your pocket
exactly
but it's way deeper than that okay
because what i'm
interested in i think what we all are on
social media
it's not like a slot machine i mean
there's other people
through this device that i have in my
pocket i have access to
mediators of desire that are
modeling lifestyles and careers
and uh vacation destinations and all
kinds of things for me so it's not just
like the way that you know the the red
notification button
affects you know my brain i mean this is
a very kind of materialist view of it
and i think that the problem goes much
deeper than that and that the issue is
that this little device i have in my
pocket is like a dream machine that's
projecting the desires of
hundreds of millions of people to me 24
hours a day
and because i'm a memetic creature i
think we all are
i need to know what other people want
and that's the real power of social
media in my opinion
yeah it's almost like we just have to be
really careful with
the role models that we choose because
what i see is someone who
is feeling discontent they're feeling
unhappy so they go to
the internet social media websites
shopping websites to
find something to fill that void that
they're feeling and they're looking at
all the wrong places
yeah i mean there's this phenomenon of
hate watching and this is one way i
think to distinguish
you know is this person affecting me in
a positive way or in a negative way
you have to ask yourself honestly what's
going on inside of you
when you're following a person or
watching a show
or reacting to a tweet or something like
that right like
what's really getting you off yeah right
is it is it envy is it uh
hatred right so this is a real thing and
i think we have to be honest i mean some
people are very
positive influences on us but many times
our fascination with people
is because we're just constantly
measuring ourselves according to them
um and there's even a weird thing where
people like to see other people like
fail and get canceled and all this stuff
yes and i think we have to ask ourselves
like what's going on inside of us that
would
make us derive pleasure from people
saying or doing things that are you know
disturbing or
not smart i want to dig more into this
on the maximal episode because you have
a section here it's on page 121 called
the joy of hate watching
and so we're going to dive more into the
joy of hate watching and really
understanding
scapegoating as well which you you cover
pretty extensively
in the book and and i want to understand
that
that sort of shad and freud that we
experience the the hate watching the
the doubt the enjoying the downfall of
others
and maybe we can begin to understand
that not just intellectually but but
viscerally so we'll dive more into that
as well i've got to put the answer for
you actually i've got three we've
already
discussed two of them one is our desires
often lead to our
misery so you can tweet that podcast
sean also the thing you want is never
the thing you want
we all there's always the thing behind
the thing even if it's the thing you
think you want you want
ice cream i tweeted that the other the
thing you want is never the thing you
want is never the thing you want
someone's like but i want ice cream i'm
like
yeah yeah but that's not actually what
you want you want the sort of gustatory
pleasure you want the immediate sort of
dopamine rush and even below that is is
you you want the calories to sustain
yourself and maybe that's the
actual need that drives that desire but
then the the memetic desire is like oh
it was a beautiful
well-placed photo shoot of an ice cream
cone on the billboard that made me want
the ice cream right
uh one more pick the answer for you uh
what you want usually isn't what you
desire
ryan and i often try to make a
distinction between these two now i know
we use these
in our culture we use those two terms
synonymously and i i'm not trying to say
that
that we we shouldn't do that but quite
often understanding
you know the true desires of that are
sort of based on the needs versus
yeah that'd be nice to have you know i
like i want a million dollars
like in the sense that like yeah that'd
be nice to have but
i don't actually desire it in the sense
that like i'm not willing to put
advertisements on this podcast because i
could make
a million dollars if we did that right
and so
being able to i guess distinguish
between the two
the the sort of the the true desire that
are attached to our needs versus
the ones that are might be attached to
some sort of cultural
influence yeah i love that man uh my
pith answer is this
more media more misery low medium oh
misery that's right and but here's the
thing is
you know i think about when i started
down my minimalism journey
i started realizing that you know the gq
magazine
the l magazine the things that i was
watching on tv
it was influencing all of these desires
that i had so i think
you know for someone uh like brenda here
you've really got to be careful with the
media
that you're bringing into your life we
all want to be entertained it's okay to
be entertained
but if we're gorging if we are becoming
a media glutton
then uh we're going to have a lot of
these mimetic desires
that uh brenda's trying to avoid here
well my pithy answer would be
follow your desires to the end
to learn what it is you really want get
underneath your
thin desires and try to uncover the
thick one that is underneath
the thin one yeah to give you an example
a kid
who's addicted to porn that's a thin
desire
okay might get them off for five minutes
or whatever it is okay
but like what is he really looking for
human connection relationship like
keep going there right because there's
something that
this person really wants right some
thick desire underneath that so i would
say like
take take whatever your thin desire is
and just keep
exploring it and find out like at the
end
where is that leading you like it might
just be
um a veneer of something that that you
really want that might
really bring you fulfillment yes yeah
yeah so if you dig
deep enough you realize like these sort
of the facade desires that surface level
desire
nothing wrong with those things but if
we understand what's behind
those you might find fulfillment behind
those initial desires
we got so much more to talk about but
first ryan you got something for us
here are some voicemail comments and
insights from our listeners
check them out hi this is scott from
kansas city listening to
the podcast on hope and your caller john
who called in said he'd
gotten into minimalism and yet
had not experienced the joy well i would
suggest
minimalism has nothing to do with stuff
minimalism is the first step
in an unconscious rejection of the
social contract that says
stuff is the answer stuff at the answer
of cell
at the expense of self at the expense of
identity
at the expense of dreams so what john
needs to do
is recognize that stuff getting rid of
stuff
only clears the deck and now he's free
to put in the work to discover
what he values what he hopes for the
real goal is to discover yourself
my name is susan and i recently listened
to your donations episode
and i just want to say that i work at a
goodwill
as a job coach in the donations centers
with adults with disabilities
and i super love my job
i love every i love going to work every
single day and i love the people i work
with
but one thing i've noticed that a lot of
donors don't know about
is that while goodwill has like
thousands of locations
all across the nation every goodwill
is run locally and specializes in
different local issues
so the goodwill in my town we specialize
in
domestic violence victims and people
with autism
but the next big city in in my state
they specialize with
a lot of homeless populations and a lot
of at-risk youth
so that's something that i would just
recommend that everybody to like
really look into your goodwill like your
local goodwill
because you can really see on how they
create a lot of local change and you can
get involved in that too
all right y'all thanks again to luke
burgess for joining us today you can
check out his book
wanting and you can find him over at
lukeburgess.com we'll put a link to both
of those
in the show notes but stay tuned he's
going to be joining us on the maximal
episode
this thursday over on the minimalist
private podcast check that out
over on patreon patreon.com the
minimalists
real quick for right here right now
here's one thing that's going on in the
life of the minimalist actually
here are four things that are going on
in the life of the minimalists ryan
uh number one is we're going to be
looking for some podcast interns
soon details coming if you're on our
email list you'll be
the first to know about that ryan needs
someone to get his coffee for him
and uh i don't know what else you need
them to do really can i just be the
intern
[Laughter]
no it'd be a disaster
speaking of not disasters man it's been
a long time in the making i just want to
say thank you for the folks who
participated
so over the last few years we raised
some money and
spent a lot of our own money as well to
help build
a grocery store a non-profit grocery
co-op on the west side of dayton our
hometown
it's called the gym city market we're
going to put a link to this in the show
notes in fact shawna you can put a link
to the most recent dayton business
journal article or maybe dayton daily
news article
they're finally opening their doors so
west dayton second or third largest food
desert in the united states
not a single grocery store until now you
did it y'all
yes you did it so many of you
contributed a dollar so
many of you contributed dozens of
dollars hundreds of dollars even some of
you
no matter how much you contributed thank
you we're really grateful
we were able to raise over a hundred
thousand dollars with the final hundred
thousand dollars they needed
to really get this thing over the finish
line we broke ground a couple years ago
before the pandemic but now we are
finally
opening the doors the gym city market
dayton ohio
not only providing healthy high quality
food to the residents there so they're
no longer just buying food
at the local corner store or at
a mcdonald's down the street but
accessible food but also
health education and understanding
what is going to provide nourishment to
people on the west side of dayton
instead of
going to a convenience store and buying
processed packaged foods they're laden
with seed oils and
preservatives and all this other
nonsense so the gym city market is
opening right now thanks to you all
we're really grateful
we'll put a link to that in the show
notes all right ryan the third thing i
want to cover really quick is we are
simplifying our patreon tiers
you know when we started patreon a while
ago a long time ago years ago
it was a per creation sort of thing yeah
and uh
we realized like it would be simpler if
we could just do it per month
right patreon eventually realized this
as well now they're encouraging all
their creators in fact
the 95 plus percent of their creators on
patreon
they do a per month so no matter how
many private podcasts we put out there
so
if next month we wanted to do 30 private
podcasts in a month
we wouldn't charge you for every single
one and so effective
immediately by the time you're listening
to this we have new simplified tiers now
no confusion there if you're a patreon
member from before it's not like you're
paying more or anything like that
it's just we've simplified things we
want to avoid confusion people reach out
to us
sean i don't know how many people reach
out to you but it's dozens a week
uh reach out to us as the minimalists
and they're like hey um
if i sign up for patreon how many
episodes am i paying for a week and
and we wanted to simplify things patreon
finally worked it out with us allowed us
to make that switch before
we couldn't make the switch we wanted to
simplify things for you so it's great
news
for you it simplifies things it makes
you confident that you
don't have to worry about i'm going to
spend too much money this month on
patreon no it's the same
amount of money every single month it
adds that consistency for you
and for us it removes all the confusion
patreon.com the minimalist you want to
support the podcast keeps the podcast
100 advertisement free and it allows us
to do something
really awesome this is our fourth update
for right here right now
we're building out a brand new studio
yeah we just put up a a
before studio tour like part one to the
studio tour
on patreon you get to see what the empty
white box studio looks like before we
start going in there with sound panels
and furniture and set design all these
things
and there's gonna be a follow-up to that
as well jordan filmed that with me
uh just a couple weeks ago and now it's
up there you can find that over
on our patreon page as well for our
added value this week ryan
we have two added values i was talking
to you we were in nashville recently
driving around
and i was telling you about this show
it's called calls
it's on apple tv plus jordan have you
heard of this show
no he's shaking his head no so i
i don't know how to describe it it's a
just a new innovation
in filmmaking and storytelling in
television i don't even know if we call
these things television anymore i mean
they call it apple tv so i guess it
is but it's not linear television that
we're used to from before
but this show it's the short episodic
the name says it all calls but
it's visual but it's not cinematic
uh it's graphical but it's also
based on the audio it could be a podcast
but also it requires the visuals so it
couldn't just be an audio podcast it
would be a different thing if it was
audio only
it's almost like you take the best of
sort of storytelling and highly produced
radio
and drama of a film but then the audio
of podcasts and it's all me i've never
seen anything like it
and bex and i turn it on and the
episodes are short they're less than 20
minutes somewhere like 15 minutes or
whatever
we have this little rule we'll set a
timer on the phone say hey siri set a
five minute timer if we're going to
watch something we give so all right
we're going to give it five minutes
and after five minutes i was all the way
in the rabbit hole
and i was like oh i want to see the next
episode they're so short i could see
the next one i don't want to spoil
anything for you but it manipulates
the reason you'll like it right you're
really into sort of physics and quantum
physics
it manipulates time through audio in a
way that's really hard for me to explain
anyway the show was called calls and
jordan i know
being the filmmaker you are really
appreciating the the innovations
that we've been seeing recently on
places like youtube and other streaming
platforms this is so
innovative that it's unlike anything
i've ever seen the storytelling
the the graphics the audio everything
the acting the drama
all of it i want to play you out today
with
speaking of innovating our friend matt
carney who we actually did an interview
with over on
patreon he has a new album out it's
called january flower
and this is one of the singles from that
album it is nice the whole thing's out
now it is out right now awesome
it is called anywhere with you enjoy the
song
by the way we have a bunch more surprise
questions this week like how do i
address my longing for things that are
impossible to attain like being young
again or bringing back
loved ones who have passed why do we
want the belongings of loved ones that
have passed
even if there's no sentimental
attachment also
what did the minimalists really want
we're going to get behind ryan's and my
deep memetic desires one desire i even
had from
childhood that i've carried with me that
we're gonna reconcile and
and luke's gonna peek behind the curtain
with us plus we have a million
more questions about why we want what we
want why we consume what we consume
what we can do to help our children
better understand
much much more if you want to hear all
that join us on the minimalist private
podcast
this week visit theminimalists.com
support to subscribe and get your
personal link
so that our private podcast plays in
your favorite podcast
app you can follow the minimalists on
facebook twitter and instagram
at the minimalist come to one of our
live podcast shows visit
theminimalist.com
tour to find a city near you if you have
a question comment or minimalism tip for
our podcast email a voice memo
to podcast at the minimalists.com you
can comment on this episode at
youtube.com slash the minimalist and if
you want our show notes in your inbox
sign up for our email list over at the
minimalists.com you'll also receive
any new minimalist writings that we put
out there for free right there in your
inbox
and ryan if they leave here today with
just one message
let it be this love people and use
things
because the opposite never works thanks
for listening y'all we'll see you next
time
[Music]
every little thing you think that you
need
every little thing you think that you
need
every little thing that's just feeding
your greed oh i bet that you'll be fine
without it